blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman well the battle against the
coronavirus is not going to be ending
anytime soon if you've been following
the numbers you know that not only are
the numbers in the united states in
general really not looking good
disproportionately so of course among
the unvaccinated
but we also have some states that are at
their pandemic peaks now there are
pandemic peaks now in terms of daily
cases they are in pandemic peaks now in
terms of total hospitalizations and the
death numbers are going very much in the
wrong direction again mostly
unvaccinated people
but
there is this question
of what about the vaccinated because
there is no question that we are seeing
breakthrough cases which are mostly mild
but we're seeing breakthrough
hospitalizations as well although
relatively fewer in number and we're
seeing breakthrough deaths as well and
there's early data from israel
showing that it starts to seem
it seems as though it starts maybe
around five six months and then there's
a noticeable drop off at the eighth
eight month mark
that there is declining uh efficacy in
these vaccines and so the question of a
third booster dose has been raised
over the last several weeks and month
and we now have heard
from the cdc
the us will begin
wide distribution of coveted booster
shots next month
saying vaccine protection wanes over
time there's a good uh write-up about
this on cnbc
and these are third doses third doses
for people who have already had two
doses of moderna or two doses of pfizer
like i and many of you in the audience
have as well
the article writes the us will start
widely distributing coveted booster
shots next month as new data shows
vaccine protection wanes over time top
u.s health officials announced wednesday
it is now quote very clear that immunity
starts to fall after the initial two
doses and with the dominance of the
delta variant quote we are starting to
see evidence of reduced protection
against mild and moderate disease
according to the statement signed by cdc
director rochelle wallensky let's go now
to rachelle wallensky speaking yesterday
and listen to what she had to say
through the end of july and early august
three points are now very clear first
vaccine-induced protection against
sars-kobi-2 infection begins to decrease
over time now important she's talking
there about infection now next she will
talk about the other elements
second vaccine effectiveness against
severe disease hospitalization and death
remains relatively high yes and third
vaccine effectiveness is generally
decreased against the delta variant so
let's jump into the data
on this slide you will see two studies
one from new york and one an analysis of
data from the mayo clinic
from may 3rd through july 25th new york
examined covet 19 tests and linked them
to individuals vaccination status based
on the state's vaccine records this is
huge this allowed new york to study
vaccine effectiveness against infection
over time for more than 10 million new
yorkers of all ages
vaccine effectiveness in may during as
early during the vaccine rollout in the
state was 92
in the later months further from
vaccination vaccine effectiveness
declined to 80 percent these data will
be published in the mmwr today
the mayo clinic analysis looked at
vaccine effectiveness for both the
pfizer and madonna vaccines
so what is the point here the point here
is
over time efficacy wanes
and um there's really two aspects to
this and this is we we don't know the
answer to this but this is a really
important thing to understand
the efficacy in the real world
is in part waning because the virus
variant that is dominant now is not the
one that the vaccine was developed
against
this is different then vaccine efficacy
goes down against the live variant the
original variant against which the
vaccines were were designed it may or it
may not but we don't yet have reason to
believe that and so this may well become
like a flu shot type situation
where i'm scheduled to get my flu shot
in a few days myself the flu shot i will
get in a few days is based on what was
believed to be the dominant strain at
the time that this year's flu shot
started to be developed i don't know if
it's six or eight months ago
and depending on how well that matches
what's actually out there in this
upcoming flu season i will have a lower
or higher degree of protection and
similarly
uh when we talk about the covet 19
vaccine
the uh same same question applies which
is how uh how how closely
does the variant that is dominant match
what the vaccines were designed for so
this is this is where we are going
and
the the
guidance as as far as we understand it
now
is going to be
starting eight months after your second
dose of the pfizer or moderna vaccine
for me
i received my second dose
february 26th so i would become eligible
um on october 26th and if that's the
case and the vaccine is available i will
go and get a third shot because i want
to not only protect myself but protect
people around me
there are of course people who have not
gotten any vaccine and don't plan to who
are going to take this as an opportunity
to say now i'm definitely not getting
the vaccine even though they already
definitely weren't getting the vaccine
because they will say this is just part
of the plot to get us more and more and
more doses forever well when something
becomes endemic like flu
that's the way it will sometimes work
and that's the way it does work with flu
so of course people who want to see a
conspiracy will see one anywhere they
want they will see it in evidence and
they will see it in the absence of
evidence and these are not really good
faith actors that we can deal with in
any serious way but this is where we are
right now and many people are feeling
and understandably so will this ever end
like is this ever going to go away and
the answer is
it may not ever go away as an endemic
thing that is just circulating with
peaks and valleys sort of like flu
but if we get enough people vaccinated
and eventually it seems likely we would
have a reformulated vaccine tailored to
maybe the delta variant maybe to a
variant that is still sometime in the
future or we can get it under control
from the standpoint of it being a
pandemic but
certainly you know things like masks on
planes have been extended until january
at minimum until january um we are
starting to see vaccine requirements at
increasingly um in different cities and
states to go to restaurants to go to
indoor venues this this stuff is not
going to end anytime soon and of course
part of the reason is a whole bunch of
people
still are not interested in getting
vaccinated at least one doctor and i'm
going to talk about this next is saying
he will no longer treat unvaccinated
patients
all right i want to talk next about the
things that different people are doing
in response to what's going on with the
coronavirus pandemic there are people
who in their place of business if they
control if they have a place of business
and they have control over what goes on
there
are saying my employees need to be
vaccinated or my customers need to be
vaccinated or you need a negative test
if you're not vaccinated or whatever one
alabama doctor is now saying
he is not going to treat
unvaccinated people
he will not see unvaccinated patients in
his office dr jason valentine is a
physician at mobile's diagnostic and
medical clinic infirmary health
posted a photo on his facebook page so
showing him next to a sign that says
effective october 1st 2021 dr valentine
will no longer see patients that are not
vaccinated against covid19 since posting
the sign valentine wrote three
unvaccinated patients asked where they
could get a vaccine
no conspiracy theories no excuses just
where do they go
valentine had a blunt answer from those
who asked him about his decision if they
asked why i told them covet is a
miserable way to die and i can't watch
them die like that
valentine said he's currently in the
process of mailing a letter to patients
about his decision he posted a copy of
the letter online
we do not yet have any great treatments
for severe disease he wrote
but we do have great prevention with
vaccines unfortunately many have
declined to take the vaccine and some
end up severely ill or dead i cannot and
will not force anyone to take the
vaccine but i also cannot continue to
watch my patients suffer and die from an
eminently preventable disease therefore
as of october 1st i will no longer see
patients that have not been vaccinated
against covid19 if you wish to keep me
as your physician documentation of your
vaccination will suffice if you wish to
choose another physician we will be
happy to transfer your records now a
bunch of people wrote to me about the
story and said isn't this a violation of
the hippocratic oath don't doctors have
a duty to treat those who are in need of
treatment and the answer is yes
but this is not an emergency physician
this is someone who this is primary care
this is someone who's saying in my
office
my roster of patience will not include
unvaccinated people
and this is not emergency medicine this
is not a doctor having someone showing
up
needing to be put
on a ventilator in an emergency room and
he says
now i'm going to look away i'm not going
to provide you any treatment this is not
emergency medicine this is primary care
so it's you know focusing on the
hippocratic oath aspect of this is not
an honest assessment of the situation
what we do need to be thinking about
here
is
that there is a burden
that is larger than it needs to be being
placed on the medical system being
placed on providers doctors nurses and
others and it is a perfectly reasonable
thing to say wait a second
if much of this the vaccine's not
perfect
okay you could still get a case with the
vaccine you could end up in the hospital
you could end up dying even when
vaccinated but it dramatically reduces
your odds so if we have that as a
possibility
what else can we be doing what else can
doctors be doing to say the burden needs
to be reduced let's find a way to
encourage people to go and get
vaccinated now i took a call on the show
a couple of weeks ago
where the viewer actually said
shouldn't when we triage in an emergency
room
take unvaccinated people and triage them
lower priority than vaccinated people so
that we don't say to the person who got
into a car accident your treatment will
be delayed because of unvaccinated
people and my answer was no i don't see
any way that you do that uh legally i
don't see any way that you do that
morally or ethically from the standpoint
of when you're in an emergency room
situation
you're triaging based on severity and
other factors
um and i i don't think that that would
make sense but increasingly if primary
care doctors want to say hey listen at
my office if you want to be under my
care under primary care if you want to
come in because you might have a sinus
infection or you have you know headache
or you have whatever reason people go
into primary care
you need to be vaccinated because i need
to reduce the burden
um then that is something that they can
do and many doctors could could do this
and ultimately people are going to have
to make a decision do i want to have a
primary care doctor
um and get the vaccine or do i want to
remain unvaccinated and maybe be unable
to find one now of course most primary
care doctors are not going to do this so
it's really academic to say what if
every primary care doc did this but good
for this doctor this doctor is doing
something to try to encourage people to
get vaccinated at least three of his
patients have said i'm going to go and
do it because i want to remain under
your care send me your thoughts about
this
as well as other ways
that the medical community could
encourage people to go and get
vaccinated you can find me on twitter at
deepakman we will be speaking very soon
about our upcoming 1
billion views on youtube milestone it's
an insane milestone for a show like ours
more on that upcoming
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
let's remember that the david pakman
show is independent media funded
primarily by viewers and listeners like
you you can sign up and support today
through the membership program at
joinpacman.com
and you do get
uh some really great perks including
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show every day access to the
bonus show an extra program every single
day the members only newsletter the
occasional member-only town halls and so
many other things grab a membership at
joinedpakman.com
i was thrilled to be back yesterday from
my vacation many many people
uh really mad at me that i was gone for
10 days even though we had guest hosts
i'm going to tell you a little bit about
that but in so doing we're going to go
through some interesting posts from the
david pakman show subreddit there are
now more than 32 000 of our viewers and
listeners subscribed for free to the
subreddit you can find it at
davidpakman.com
reddit whether you want to complain
about my vacations talk about
afghanistan talk about care policy it's
wide open well-moderated respectful
mostly respectful discussion
davidpakman.com reddit up here's just an
example post
david needs to come back now i miss him
which i love to see that i really was
flattered
at
the number of people
that count on me
and wanted me back
during my vacation it was flattering is
really the only way i can describe it
and also
i got a bunch of really ugly ugly
messages from people david how dare you
be on break
uh i uh watch your videos every day and
you just leave and you're on vacation
um
okay i mean i guess yeah you know the
show is free right i mean it's the the
show the show is free
i also got a couple of emails from
people who
thought i would or suggested that i
cancel my trip like halfway through when
the afghanistan stuff happened it's like
even if that made sense
um does anybody know how complicated it
is like at this point you need covet
tests to get back to the country
changing flights last minute is
outrageously expensive and accommodation
i mean that seemed like an unreasonable
expectation but i'm going to focus on
the positive not the people threatening
to never watch again because i took a
vacation the number of people that wrote
me messages saying david you know when
you were gone i realized i really look
forward to listening to the show and
watching the clips each day i love that
i'm flattered by that and i'm glad to be
back another post from the david pakman
show subreddit about independent media
this is a really interesting uh post
actually
do you user knower of stuff asked
do you think a big issue with new media
is that commentators at some point will
have to choose between pandering to
their audience rather than being
objective and telling them what they
need to hear or risk losing viewership
yes
we've talked about this this you you
could describe that as the phenomenon of
audience capture
where the entity the show the host
becomes captured by the audience and has
to do what the audience wants or expect
rather than what they believe or or
believe is best i have made a commitment
and i've talked about this before
we sometimes disagree by we i mean my
audience with me or parts of my audience
with me we sometimes disagree about
things there's disagreement right now
with some in my audience about
afghanistan there's been disagreement in
the past about all sorts of different
issues sometimes you know there's like a
vaccine skeptical component of the
audience there's people in the audience
who didn't like my view of the
israeli-palestinian conflict or whatever
but the promise i've made is i want to
be the anti-grifter in the sense that
i'm just going to tell you what i
believe
and i'm not going to tell you what i
think the audience wants to hear because
i don't want to lose a portion of the no
if there's any criticism of what i say
on the show
it should be substantive because you
disagree with me or think that i'm wrong
but not because anybody thinks that i'm
coming up with a take that will be the
best for the audience so that we don't
lose viewership that's never been what
i've done so that's been my commitment i
think i've stuck to it last post i want
to highlight
uh yes i did have
uh sort of one of these accidental uh
portmentos yesterday i used the word
question eight
uh and i meant questioning
and vaccinate i some kind of
questionating i put it together and user
puzza puzza saying
people should not be questionating the
wisdom of getting inoculated against
cobit and i can absolutely agree with
that if people want to put that on urban
dictionary by all means go ahead but
there is no we should not question it
question 8 would be questioning
vaccination let's do it let's get
ourselves vaccinated all right join the
discussion at davidpakman.com
reddit we have seen a lot of things get
kind of wacky and backwards in the
aftermath of joe biden pulling troops
from afghanistan and of course that
created a vacuum in which the taliban
has retaken control of the country now
i'm not going to redo yesterday's
segment where i outline my position on
this in full but in short i agree with
joe biden's decision i said this
yesterday i think there would have been
chaos whenever we ultimately left
afghanistan
but the afghanistan incursion has been a
failure a more u.s involvement for more
time wouldn't help anything the longer
we stay the more money is spent to
ultimately achieve nothing our
involvement is a negative it's not a
positive
and one of the things that we're seeing
is all sorts of people on the left on
the right for different reasons now say
we have to go back into afghanistan
that's one thing we're seeing there's
all of a sudden people saying no we got
to go back it was a mistake to leave
we've got to do more nation-building and
peacekeeping and world policing and all
this stuff let's go back in that's weird
but another of the strange things we're
seeing and i'm not even saying i know
what to make of it but another thing
we're seeing is some really bizarre kind
of like revisionist histories
and apologizing for the taliban which
has now taken control now i will be the
first to admit
the taliban
is more complicated than just like one
explanation like sharia law
okay well yeah i mean sharia law can
mean different things in different
countries but
there are now
some people framing the taliban as sort
of like maybe kind of good
and i'm finding it really weird and
today we're going to look at a clip of
british chief of defense staff general
sir nick carter that's actually his
title i'm not like doing the sir routine
uh general sir nick carter who was on
sky news talking about kind of like the
taliban's not that bad
and so let's just get into it check out
the words he uses and how he describes
the taliban now carter was in
afghanistan in 2004 commanding british
troops there had additional deployments
to afghanistan and remember the taliban
is a radical group considered a
terrorist group by multiple governments
including canada turkey and others the
u.s has never recognized the taliban
government although i don't believe the
u.s considers the taliban a terrorist
group
trump was just negotiating with them
months ago so here we go let's take a
look and check this out and how do you
feel about collaborating with the enemy
when
they have carried out such atrocities
against um uk military personnel over
the years i think you have to be very
careful using the word enemy um i think
people need to understand who the
taliban actually are and of course what
they are a disparate collection of
tribes people as president karzai put it
to me only yesterday they're country
boys
and the plain fact is that they happen
to live by a code of honor so
these are these are tribes people
they're country boys
and they live by a code of honor almost
implying like that's a good thing
on its face now code of honor code of
honor could be anything you could have a
code of honor that is uh horrifying and
there are many examples of that uh but
he continues to sort of say this is not
this is maybe not so bad of a group
understand it which has been their
standard for many many years it's called
pashtun wally it has honor at the heart
of what they do they are bound together
by a common purpose which is they don't
like corrupt governance they don't like
governance that is self-serving and they
want an afghanistan that is inclusive
for all wow i mean that that's sounding
pretty good right i mean it's all about
honor these are country boys
they're very much against corruption
well corruption's bad so being against
corruption must be good
and they're for inclusion i mean that
that's all pretty good stuff right now
while in power in afghanistan when you
look at the history the taliban became
notorious
for their misogyny and their violence
against women period forcing full burke
or wearing at all at all times
systematic gender segregation
women not allowed to work women not
allowed to be educated past age 8 only
allowed to go to a male doctor if they
have a male chaperone to take them
public floggings and executions for
women for violating taliban law
occasionally forcing into child marriage
and on and on and on so maybe he's
saying it would be different now or
something but but we don't actually have
reason to think that that's the case so
let's continue here so i think rather
than talking about
what except women
well again i think we have to wait and
see i mean i don't know what they mean i
can't support the way that they treat
women we surely well i think you have to
listen to what they're saying at the
moment and i think you have to listen to
the facts on the ground they're saying
they are definitely
what they're saying is using this coded
language about the involvement of women
in society
uh as dictated by religious law right
and so you have to be you have to
understand uh that that's an
extraordinarily cynical way to talk
about inclusion oh yeah and i'm not
saying that's anything that you and i
would approve of particularly i'm just
going to find that absolutely but i do
and i'll go back just a second because
sharia law is mentioned here acts on the
ground they are definitely
in law yeah and i'm not saying that's
anything that you and i would approve of
particularly
absolutely but i do think that they have
changed i think they recognize that over
the course of the last 20 years
afghanistan has evolved they recognize
the fundamental role that women have
played in that evolution and yes they at
the moment will undoubtedly say that
they want to respect women's rights
under islamic law and that will be a
sharia law but that doesn't necessarily
mean that they won't allow them to be
involved in government and in education
and in medicine and those things that
they need them to be involved in now
i i don't want to just slam this guy
like the there is there's an aspect of
this that i think
you know we
i am not for sharia law i'm not for any
religious law being the government law
civil law okay like no matter what it is
i don't want the christian version of
sharia that some of these right-wingers
want in the u.s i don't i'm against
sharia law but if we're going to have a
more nuanced understanding of this
sharia can mean different things in
different places and we have to
understand that like for example there's
full sharia criminal law which is
outrageous i mean just completely
outrageous
there's also
sharia law like in egypt okay where
the penal and civil codes are basically
based on 19th century french law as in
the as is the case in many parts of the
world
um but but there is sharia law uh in the
country um uh it in some more general uh
religious uh kind of mix with the
government but the the penal code the
civil law uh is still is still based on
19th century french law so the point
here is
it's true that sharia law is not one
thing
but there's no reason to think based on
the history of the taliban
that
they would go in the direction of egypt
historically the taliban has gone more
in the direction of full sharia criminal
law
let's let's look just to the last few
seconds of this clip
so i think we have to be patient we have
to give them the space to show how they
are going to step up to the plate and
whether or not we can work with them
will very much depend upon how they
treat all afghans okay so it's sort of
just like a weird soft apologetics for
the taliban and this is just one example
and to be clear i'm not saying the
taliban's bad so we got to send troops
in no i'm glad the troops are coming out
even though some now went back in we
talked about that yesterday
but some of the weird apologetics that
we're seeing for the taliban absent any
reason to think that the taliban has
really changed i just find bizarre so i
want to hear from you about this we're
going to have more coverage of this
story on the david pakman show instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
while you're there you can also follow
me on instagram at david.pakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
alright so i think something is going on
this week from the standpoint of the
former president donald trump and trump
supporters i want to go over it with you
right now as many of you might remember
august was supposedly a very important
month for many trump supporters when
donald trump was supposedly going to be
reinstated of course it's not going to
happen but donald trump is going to be
speaking at a rally in coleman alabama
this saturday uh after being basically
missing from from the public
in any real way for about a month and in
the lead up to this rally on saturday at
which now listen to this
there are some trump supporters who
believe trump will be reinstated at the
rally in alabama saturday i mean just
you know we don't even have to delve
into that
um but donald trump has done a couple of
interviews in the last couple of days
with sean hannity which we'll look at
first and then with maria bartoromo
which we will look at second um this
first interview
i i really don't know what to make of
this donald trump looks like he either
just woke up
um people emailed me saying trump
actually seemed senile in this interview
trump is rumpled he's disheveled his
right eye is again almost completely
swollen shut which seems to be pretty
common now in the interviews he just
looks like he woke up as the interview
was starting and started answering the
first question which made very little
sense let's just jump right in
well it's good to be with you sean but
it's a terrible time for our country i
don't think in
all of the years our country has ever
been so humiliated i don't know would
you call it a military defeat or a
psychological defeat there's never been
anything like what's happened here now
if you're wondering what the hell is he
talking about he's talking about leaving
afghanistan which is exactly what he
planned to do he just ran out of time to
do it
you can go back to jimmy carter with the
hostages
yeah so the hot stages were definitely
something that trump looked at very
strongly that right eye almost swollen
shut trump making absolutely no sense
and then it goes from strange optics
to strange substance with trump claiming
that the taliban has been fighting for a
thousand years the taliban was formed in
1994.
uh what is he got what is this guy
talking about oh we did a terrible thing
but think of what's happening now i've
heard as many as 40 000 americans and
the taliban good fighters i will tell
you they're good fighters we have to
give them credit for that they've been
fighting for a thousand years that's
what they do is they fight the top
so praising the taliban but also a
thousand years ban has circled the
airport
and who knows if they're going to treat
us right you know all of them yeah so
making very very little sense
then as if that's not weird enough
in the next segment this is a 90-second
trump rant
related to the criticisms of how trump
planned to do the same thing biden did
in afghanistan
but he's incoherent and he's slurring
and i can't tell what point he's trying
to make
i thought it would maybe run through
bureaucracy it doesn't you need somebody
up there that they're going to respect
so when they say oh he talked to the
taliban you remember they were
criticizing me they criticized me when i
talked to kim jong-un
well president biden told me it's the
single biggest problem we have i said
have you ever called him have you ever i
mean listen the criticism of his
conversation with kim jong-un was trump
thought that the concessions kim jong-un
made
mattered that they had any substance
behind them when they're the same
concessions that north korean leaders
have been pretending to make to the us
for 40 years
and other presidents know not to fall
for them trump fell for it that was the
criticism no i haven't
he did try but he was not it was not
receptive on the other side but it was
receptive with me with me now we were
supposed to have a war and probably a
very big nuclear war
i get along with him great and i got
along with him great he doesn't like
biden much i'll tell you that but i
guess this is about supposedly this is
about afghanistan along with him great
and we had no problems you remember that
it was we were virtually remember the
big button versus the little button and
the whole thing let me just we get along
great we had a very good relationship we
met
got no credit for that one
no problem well he accomplished nothing
by the way south korea i got them to pay
billions of dollars billions we're
protecting south korea they're very
wealthy they built the ships they built
the televisions they built they do
everything they're very rich
they were paying us nothing
i got them to pay billions and billions
of dollars because we're protecting them
from north korea and i had a very good
relationship okay so supposedly that was
about afghanistan but then he's talking
about kim jong-un and all sorts of just
completely free it's free association
it's it's it's almost freudian in nature
where the interviewer yeah
the whole thing hannity is asking
questions
but he would almost get the same stuff
if he took a freudian approach where the
psychotherapist says almost nothing and
like doesn't even steer the conversation
at all um okay we'll continue then the
vaccine comes up and trump says yeah the
vaccine is good but freedom is important
and you know if you want wear your mask
but yeah freedom is important but i
would i would love people to take the
vaccine in the meantime
wear your mask if you want but if you
want again
you want your freedoms you have to have
your freedoms right so yeah i mean i
guess all else being equal sure get
vaccinated but freedom and you know if
you want wear your mask but freedom the
freedom part is really really important
and then donald trump says
now they i i genuinely don't understand
this
it seems that hannity asks trump
what would you do if you were president
right now
and trump seems to say i can't tell you
if i'm running because of campaign
finance i've watched this clip five
times i think that that's what happened
see if you can figure it out are you
considering a run again in 2024 i'll let
you answer it any way you want but i'll
go back to our original question so
hannity mentions the 24 but then he goes
to a question now that we have
all these americans behind enemy lines
do you have in the 45 seconds we have
left
what what would you do now to help that
with that specific situation
so because the campaign finance laws are
extremely complicated and unbelievably
stupid i'm actually not allowed to
answer that question can you believe it
i'd love to answer it but let me put it
this way i think you'll be happy and i
think a lot of our now that's not true
trump trump can say whether his
intention is to run or not
what he may be referring to in his weird
free association cloud9 sort of way
is that
there may be additional scrutiny upon
all the money being donated to him if he
were to say that he's running but
trump's free to tell us if he intends to
run or not it's weird that he keeps
repeating that okay here now we get i
guess to the answer about what would he
do friends will be very happy but i'm
not actually allowed to answer it it
makes it very difficult if i do so
people you're going to be happy because
i love this country and i hate to see
what's happening would you be willing
okay so what trump won't tell us what he
would do
and he also won't tell us whether he's
running this man is worshipped by
tens of millions of americans
and that's a really really scary thought
so that was on hannity
bizarre rumpled crumpled disheveled
swollen interview
and
all of this leading up to this rally
he's doing on saturday let's go next to
his interview yesterday with fox host
maria bartoromo so now we're going to
get to the second interview that trump
did in the last couple of days
this one was with total pro
sycophant maria bartoromo of fox news
and fox business fame i've talked before
you know when i was starting to get into
following the stock market and learning
about uh
that type of thing and personal finance
etc maria bartoromo was really a
groundbreaking reporter on cnbc uh first
woman to report from the floor of the
new york stock exchange and she would do
good interviews with ceos and ask real
questions somehow now she's just a trump
brown-noser spreading conspiracy
theories and screaming
um
and the theme of this interview
is really revisionist history
here is donald trump claiming
covid was over when i left office now
that's not true you might you might
remember that's that wasn't true but
let's listen same time some people don't
want to take it and you know when i was
president you didn't have this problem
with people not wanting to take it
they don't take it because they don't
trust biden and they don't trust the
biden administration now let's add some
reality to this issue
when donald trump left office
900 000 people a day were getting
vaccines
it was almost exclusively health care
workers and the oldest and most health
compromised
nobody was really in a position of
deciding whether or not to get the
vaccine because there were almost no
vaccines available when donald trump
left office when i was president you
didn't have people protesting the
vaccine
because there was no vaccine to get just
think back everybody wanted to get it
and we were giving out over a million
shots a day now trump's lying about a
million a day it was nine hundred
thousand overstating it by more than ten
percent but also the issue there about
people people weren't protesting and
everybody wanted to get it people
weren't protesting because there weren't
yet enough vaccines available for it to
be a thing and number two it's not true
everyone wanted to get it in fact
more people when trump left office said
i'm never getting the vaccine the number
of anti-vaxxers has declined since trump
left office everything he's saying here
is a lie we had that thing rocking and
he's now president and he's doing a
lousy job at coronavirus they
coronavirus is back if that ever
happened to me where it came back okay
when i left it was all virtually gone it
was over it was a path now that's a lie
the last day trump was in office more
than 4
000 people died of covid
we now were back up to about a thousand
a day dying of covet it's a disaster
it's a tragedy and much of it is because
of anti-vaxxerism how was it over when
more than four thousand people died on
the day trump left office now it's
coming back through the delta
and i don't know if you even want to
call it that all you call it is that the
china virus is back
and so why is he doing a good job he did
a bad job with sars the h1n1 very bad
job remember that the the obama biden
had two-thirds approval
on uh on on on the h1n1 joke of a job a
horrible job all of a sudden they said
oh he's doing so well and remember h1n1
was essentially no more serious than the
flu like we stopped testing for it once
we realized that okay so trump totally
incoherent there then
trump says uh communism it's communism
what is communism editorial decisions
are communism stolen from him and he's
yes i i know the tape
yeah they can blackmail him stolen by a
russian he was sitting there with some
woman i don't know who the hell the
woman and she didn't have clothes on and
neither did he
this would have been five years ago ten
years ago the biggest scandal in history
and now they don't they don't put it on
i'm telling you this is communism what
they do is they don't put things on not
airing a story
is communism guys don't you understand
in fact last week i was on vacation i
didn't air a story about afghanistan
because i wasn't here
that was communism yeah
it's if like if something's bad about
biden they don't put it on if
something's bad about me they make it
ten times worse than they put it on if
something's good about me well we know
that's right yeah we know that's right
maria we are very important analysis
there then trump suggests without any
evidence
that we don't really need booster shots
i told you at the top of the show that
the fda is now saying
basically at the eight month mark from
receiving your second cover dose you
should get a third dose that's going to
start very soon um trump downplays that
and he's like yeah it's just
money-making for uh pfizer it's a great
point it's a great point
but i still come back to the idea i
still come back to the idea of a booster
shot i mean yes you're right that seems
to work
that sounds you know what that sounds to
me like a money-making operation for
pfizer
okay think of the money involved
tens of billions of dollars how good of
business is that if you're a pure
businessman
you say you know what let's give them
another shot that's another 10 billion
dollars
insanely insanely dangerous comment
money coming in the whole thing is just
crazy it doesn't
you wouldn't think you would need a
booster you know when these first came
out they were good for life
then they were good for a year or two
and i could see the writing on the wall
i could see the dollar signs in their
eyes of that guy that runs spicer now of
course there's so many deceptions there
first of all dollar signs in the eyes of
the guy who runs pfizer trump
hand-picked pfizer
uh as the company that he was going to
pre-purchase vaccines from in his big
heroic vaccine delivery is trump saying
that his judgment is so bad
that he did business with a prophet
monger that is that is pfizer and of
course the entire thing about the the
duration of of uh the vaccine a lot of
what's going on is that the virus is
changing the vaccine was tailored to
what was out there when the vaccine was
made
and at this point that's what over a
year ago that that was formulated um and
the virus is changing so the decrease
decreased efficacy is of course against
against delta it's just all crazy and
people hear this stuff and they believe
it which is the really dangerous thing
um okay uh last thing here this is trump
just saying things uh he he seems to be
saying he kind of like indirectly
threatened chinese president xi it's
very weird it's very bad you know i had
a great relationship with president xi
it's good as anybody's ever had
really a good relationship i spent a lot
of time with him yeah i was over there
he toured me china and places that he
toured him we're incredible actually
and i said it would be a terrible thing
if we ever fought be a terrible thing if
these beautiful places were ever blown
up
[Laughter]
be terrible if uh your entire country
here was blown up one day president xi
let's uh let's make sure that doesn't
happen
what a bizarre series of interviews and
the real question is what is the point
of all this what is trump building
towards clearly reappearing in advance
of his rally in alabama saturday night
which we'll be covering live
what is happening here what is trump
building towards let me know your
thoughts and we'll be right back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month check it
out at patreon.com david pakman show
sometimes you can sort of feel like
you're riding a propaganda wave from
right wing media one example would be
the hydroxychloroquine wave where it
built and built and built where
everybody was talking about it fox news
and donald trump and everybody's
hydroxyhydroxy and then all of a sudden
the wave crashes and that's it
hydroxychloric when nobody ever talks
about it again and right now the
propaganda wave is around the regeneron
monoclonal antibody treatment for covid
as an alternative to the vaccine as
something that tells us you don't really
have to worry that much because we've
got the monoclonal antibodies available
for whoever needs them and case in point
on fox and friends uh one of the three
hosts ainsley earhart
big purveyor of propaganda
falsely claimed
that
since you can get the regeneron
treatment
after getting infected
that's basically like getting vaccinated
now that's completely untrue again the
context of the clip is uh republican
governor greg abbott who tested positive
in texas we covered that story talked
about it um let's uh let's listen to
what ainslie earhart had to say you know
what's interesting uh greg abbott we
he's in our prayers this morning because
he announced that he tested positive for
covid yesterday he has been vaccinated
and he still got coveted um but i think
he's doing okay he's by the way that's
always like a slight hit at the vaccine
vaccinated and still got it getting the
regeneron no symptoms he said what's
interesting though is if you don't get
vaccinated and you go to the hospital
most of the time you're going to get
regeneron but regeneron are the
antibodies so you're basically still
getting vaccinated because they're
sticking you with an antibody right
regeneron is the
antibodies so you're still basically
getting vaccinated because they're
sticking you with the antibodies
the virus so so guess what they're doing
uh in this terribly run city they're
deciding you can't go to plays you can't
go to movies you can't go to bars you
can't go to restaurants you can't go to
gyms can't go to anything unless you
have your vaccination card right which
takes a dollar to make uh if a knockoff
card or yet there's a difference look at
look at brian kilmeade mentioning by the
way you can make a fake vaccination card
for a dollar that's a crime we'll get
back to that uh but this this is
becoming all the rage here's sean
hannity on fox news last night he's
trying to talk about monoclonal
antibodies he calls them
monocolonial antibodies very aggressive
to build these
these mono colonial antibody centers
it's a big issue of colonization guys
actually it's uh it's a big big thing
okay so let's talk about it now they're
saying vaccine what about the regeneron
treatment so first of all
the regeneron treatment is only
emergency use authorized by the fda
all of these people saying listen if i
get sick i'll get the antibodies and
that's safer than an experimental
unapproved covet vaccine the vaccine is
authorized by the fda under an emergency
use authorization
uh it's not fully authorized the
regeneron monoclonal antibody treatment
is likewise um authorized under
emergency use if you look at the fact
sheet it says
is this approved by the fda to treat or
prevent covid and the answer is no this
is an
investigational drug
it is not currently fda approved to
treat or prevent any disease or
condition included including covet 19.
the regeneron treatment is only
authorized under an
and it also says it is not a replacement
for vaccination against covid19 in the
same fact sheet it says
post exposure prophylaxis
with the antibody treatment is not a
substitute for vaccination against
covid19 so this is just the new thing
it's the new fad it's the new propaganda
wave that they're writing regeneron
regeneron and by the way it just so
happens that a whole bunch of elected
officials have financial interests in
regeneron so make of that what you will
we're not necessarily saying anything
about that but that that's another thing
last thing
um
i want to play again for you this is
brian kilmeade mentioning you can get a
fake vaccine card for a dollar can't go
to anything unless you have your
vaccination card right which takes a
dollar to make a a knockoff card or yeah
there's a difference so there's brian
kilmeade talking about it's cheap to get
a fake vaccine card now remember the
vaccine itself is free
okay so no matter how little you pay for
a fake vaccine card the vaccine it's
safe is free and the paper won't protect
you the actual vaccine will but i want
to remind people
it is a crime to have or to make or or
present for use
a fake
cdc vaccination card the unauthorized
use of an official government agency
seal like the cdc or the hhs is a crime
it may be punishable under title 18 of
usc section 1017 and other applicable
laws
if you believe or you know or have
information about somebody faking a
vaccine card particularly and then using
it for something where only vaccinated
people are supposed to be or do or
whatever the case may be
you can call 1-800 hhs tips
or you can go to the internet crime
complaint center at ic3.gov you can also
call your local district attorney
state attorney general you can try local
police how much they'll know what to do
i i don't really know you might also end
up with an anti-vaxx police officer
taking your call who the hell knows but
the point here is it's against the law
um and you can report it 800 hhs tips or
ic3.gov
hey among all of this bad stuff going on
let me talk briefly about something
really exciting
uh we are approaching 1 billion that's
with a b 1 billion youtube views
you might remember that last september
right around september 15th 14th 12th
something like that
we hit an important milestone 1 million
youtube subscriptions 1 million youtube
subscribers
we are now already almost 40 beyond that
we're almost at 1.4 million subscribers
we've seen 40
subscriber growth in the last 11 months
it's incredible
but now
we're moving on to views
you can have tons of subscriptions all
over the place but if those people
aren't watching your videos it's
basically worth nothing and some
channels have that situation millions of
subscribers almost no views
we are now approaching a billion youtube
views
listen to how nuts the growth is
last year at this time
our entire channel had 600 million views
the last 400 million views are coming in
basically one year which is insane and i
have only you to thank for that we are
now
at
989 million views that's about 10
and a half million away from 1 billion
now how long is this going to take we
often get a million views in a day
but not every day so it could be nine
days if we had a really strong nine days
more likely it would be something like
two to two and a half weeks so what are
we doing for this first of all we're
putting together a fantastic billion
view compilation with a nice counter
rolling up to a billion it's going to
start with old clips and go all the way
through there's going to be classics in
there that many of our newer viewers and
listeners may never have seen so we're
putting that together it's going to be
like an eight or nine minute long clip
producer pat's been doing a great job
with it and it's going to be ready it'll
be ready to be triggered by us
surpassing one billion views that's
number one number two
yes there's going to be a huge
membership special at 1 billion of
course there is you better believe it we
are going to blow memberships out of
here like you wouldn't believe like
nobody's ever seen before in fact uh
just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com to be notified there's
no specific date because we don't know
when we're gonna hit the billion and
then number three
we want this we've never tried this
before okay here this is just an idea
we want to try to make a compilation
of people from the audience calling into
other shows they can be left-wing shows
or right-wing shows and somehow
mentioning david pakman show youtube one
billion views it can be just like hey
you call a friendly show
and you might mention hey will you be
congratulating the david pakman show on
a billion views it can be trolling of
right-wing shows whatever okay the the
only thing is just david pakman show a
billion views mentioned during a call-in
on other shows
send them in if you're able to do it i
know many of you are regular callers to
all sorts of different shows can we get
it in front of mike lindell can we get
who knows dan bongino what all these
people charlie spork um and then send us
a link we'll compile it together
and hopefully have a funny video in
addition to our billion view compilation
for you
uh by the uh i mean it really should be
early in september uh could even maybe
be in august so we'll keep uh you
updated we are at 989 million on the way
to one billion all right i've been uh
going through
a lot of voicemails i had over 600
voicemails waiting for me when i got
back from vacation
and um i found one guy i don't believe
we've ever heard from this guy before
but maybe maybe once before
who is convinced it's not going to be
august it might be september or october
definitely by january 1 donald trump
will be president again so says this
caller now remember if you want to call
the number is 219 to david p
take a listen to this
david pakman
how's it going my favorite demon rat
look i'm not a very smart man but it
doesn't take a genius to know that this
was a rigged election
trump is coming back and i don't know if
it's going to be in august september
october whatever
but it's gonna happen
in fact by the new year trump will be
back in office and i can't wait to see
your faces when that happens
god bless trump
yeah so hearing the guy say demon rap
um
it actually does ring a bell i think
that this guy may actually have called
before
that's a delusional trumpist and so
again the question is it was going to be
march and then april and then may and
then august and then now it's august
september and now this guy's saying well
definitely by january 1st
one of two things can happen one is they
just push it further oh it's going to be
february it's going to be march and then
eventually it'll be like well just vote
for trump 2024 and that's it it doesn't
become violent
the other possibility is that at a
certain point these people go nuts and
they actually go out and do real world
violence in the streets and i hope that
doesn't happen that would be horrifying
if it did
i don't know which way it's more likely
to go but we did have that report
yesterday department of homeland
security is increasingly concerned
because of the calls to violence if
trump isn't reinstated that they are
seeing
from some of these completely delusional
unhinged trumpets i'm always hoping for
the outcome that skips the violence
we've got a great bonus show for you
today
restaurant owners
will be suing new york city and bill de
blasio over the indoor vaccine mandate
not all restaurant owners a group of
restaurant owners they say it puts an
undue
uh
undue influence uh undo undo a sort of
uh apparatus infrastructure that they
can't meet they're saying this is not
like checking an id
we now have to say is this a real
vaccine card
and they are suing because many of them
don't want to do it we'll talk about
that number two a new report finds that
61 of americans paid no federal income
tax in 2020. what does this really mean
are these numbers surprising or not when
you understand how federal income tax
works
and then lastly joe biden's approval is
down below 50 for the first time ever
during his presidency and i don't think
it's a surprise as to why that's
happening i think that there has been
some disastrous press for him over the
afghanistan situation although a
majority of americans agree with the
action that he took
but the lack of another big legislative
accomplishment so far combined with some
bad press about afghanistan i am not
shocked to see biden drop below 50 we'll
talk about what it means the
implications
and what the next year has to look like
if democrats want to have a shot at
retaining control of the house and
senate in 2020. all of those stories why
am i mentioning them because they're on
today's bonus show sign up at
joinpackman.com
and
you will be instantly able to get access
to the bonus show see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman